pope francis spoke about the ongoing
conflict in his easter sunday message
from saint peter's square he expressed
his anguish over the war and hope that
peace can prevail chris van cleave
reports from london
in clear discomfort from a lingering
knee problem pope francis slowly made
his way to the balcony of saint peter's
basilica to deliver his traditional
easter speech urging the world's leaders
to strive for peace
the 85 year old pontiff described this
as an easter of war condemning the
violence in ukraine calling it cruel and
senseless implicitly criticizing russia
a message clearly resonating with the
crowd of tens of thousands
we have seen all too much blood all too
much violence in what is being
interpreted as a reference to the threat
of nuclear war francis quoted from a
1955 manifesto by philosopher bertrand
russell and physicist albert einstein
that warns of putting an end to the
human race unless mankind renounces war
to hear this stark warning the faithful
returned for the first easter weekend
since the pandemic after two years of an
empty saint peter's square the crowd
flooded into the street beyond the
square to listen and once again see pope
francis up close
but the vatican is facing criticism for
its traditional good friday procession
at rome's coliseum which included both
the ukrainian and russian cross bearer
for cbs mornings i'm chris van cleave